the third in the four species
of sharks that I wanna
share with you tonight is
the Oceanic White Tip shark,
a shark that has been listed
as the fourth most dangerous
species of sharks if you
pay attention to such lists.
It's an animal that is
a true pelagic predator.
This animal lives way
out in the open ocean,
hunts in deep water,
occasionally rises
to the surface,
it's been called the
ship wreck shark,
because there are sort of
infamous stories about them
taking out sailors
that were ship wrecked
that are drifting at sea.
But this is an animal that
has to be very efficient
at hunting.
The open ocean has been
described as the desert
and there's only pockets
of life here and there
so these animals have to be
very very good at what they do.
Oceanics tend to be
generally in size
between nine and
12 feet in length.
And they have those
beautiful long pectoral fins,
not unlike the Thresher or
the Blue shark that we saw
but even longer.
Their scientific
name, their Latin name
is longimanus which
when translated means
the long hand or
the long fingers,
which is an apt description.
You can imagine an
animal like this,
swimming up toward the surface
and then just gliding down.
Maybe a mile deep
into the ocean,
looking for prey.
Completely effortlessly
with its pectorals,
those dermal denticles,
completely hydrodynamic
just swooping in silently and
nailing some deep water fish.
Very efficient predator
and this one as you can see
is kinda, find it
beefy, kind of fat
so there's no
problem getting food.
This is an image I made that
shows that distinct shape,
the silhouette shape.
This was in a place called
Cat Island in the Bahamas.
And it was back in 2006 that
I did an expedition there
as part of a story I was
doing for National Geographic
because we had heard
some fish tales
about oceanic white tips
being seen there.
Now oceanics hadn't been seen.
I didn't know any diver that
had seen one in 20 or 30 years
in the Bahamas.
But these sport fishermen
said they were catching
yellow fin tuna and as they
were reeling in the tuna,
they said that oceanics
were stealing the fish
off their line.
So on that gamble I went
out there for 16 days
and in 16 days only found one.
But I brought a cage along
because we didn't know
what we would find,
this is Wes Pratt a shark■
biologist inside.
Turns out we were there
at the wrong time of year
but if you go at different
times of year you can see more
oceanic white tips.
But oceanic white tips,
as recently as about 1970
or in the early 70s were
described as the most abundant
large animal on the planet.
Most abundant large
animal, large meaning
anything bigger than
a hundred pounds.
So think about that,
there must have been
zillions of em out there.
Today they're 99% in decline.
They're on the
verge of extinction.
Largely because of their fins.
Their fins are highly
priced in shark fin soup.
Cat Island in the
Bahamas is one of the only
remaining pockets of
oceanic white tips
that's left on the planet.
You can find them in Hawaii,
a little bit, sporadically.
You can find them
in the red sea,
but this is really one of
the only concentrations.
This is my friend Jerome
Arrow, a shark camera man
swimming with one of them here.
So it's one of the only
places you could go
to photograph them
and for this story,
it's where I spent my time.
We have two of em
here, it's like one
is saying to the other one,
don't look now but there's
a guy taking our picture
over there.
But, it's all done
with free diving,
we're not using scuba with this,
we're just snorkeling.
Mask, snorkel,
and fins and a wet suit.
And it can get a little
interesting when there's several
of em around, there's three
in this particular frame,
especially when the
ocean is a little rough,
they'll come in and
oceanic white tips,
as Gimbel mentioned,
will often bump.
I've never seen their teeth
but unlike some of the other
species that are a little
bit more standoffish,
they are quite curious and
they will come in and bump.
And when they do that
nictitating membrane,
that white membrane
goes over their eye
to protect them.
So if they were attacking prey
that might scratch their
eye, it's an evolutionary
thing that they've developed.
But beautiful animals.
And on one of my
last days there,
I photographed this pair.
And the one in the
foreground as you see,
has a satellite tag on
it near the dorsal fin.
And these are researchers
that have begun to tag
these animals and try to
track their movements,
they don't stay at Cat Island.
And we're not quite sure I
think where they're going
so, we need to know
that information
if we're gonna be
able to protect them.
Bahamas has protected all sharks
which is a very good and
progressive thing to do
but if they go somewhere
else and get killed,
that wouldn't be good so,
it's gonna be helpful to have
that sort of information.
So I have another little
video of what it's like
diving at Cat
Island with me here,
oops, maybe we don't.
Alright, well we'll just go
right to Great White Sharks,
how's that?
So the last species off
course is Great White Sharks.
That I wanted to
share with you tonight
and as you may know, Great
Whites are the largest
predatory fish on earth.
An absolute ultimate predator.
This is an animal that
can weigh well over a ton
and has more than 300 big
serrated teeth in its mouth
and it can grow to
lengths of at least 20 feet,
some anecdotal reports
of bigger ones out there
but we know at least 20 feet.
But it's an animal that
is largely enigmatic.
We know very little
about great whites.
We don't know how
many there are,
or very much about
them in the places
that we even get to
see brief glimpses.
Now you can imagine a
terrestrial predator
the size of a
pickup truck hunting
along the coast of California.
you know, we would know
everything there is to know
about that animal.
But in the sea,
that's not the case.
We don't get that
kind of access.
So they do remain
largely enigmatic
and very mysterious.
For this story in the July
Issue of National Geographic,
I worked in two locations.
The first of which
was South Australia.
And I went to Australia
because it was a place
where I thought I had
a pretty good chance
of seeing sharks.
The first job in
doing these stories
is to be able to see the
thing you want to try
to photograph and
sometimes underwater,
that's not always so easy.
But it was also a location
where Great White Sharks
have been observed and
studied for a very long time.
And there are some new
theories emerging about them.
There's various hubs.
It was always believed that
Great Whites were loners,
that they pretty much
wandered the ocean alone
by themselves but we know
now that there is some
social behavior,
there are these hubs
where they tend to
congregate often
for feeding or mating.
But not much is really known
about those social behaviors.
This is a photo
that I made at dusk,
when we see two great
whites sort of moving in
in this hunting behavior,
they often get very frisky
at sunset time.
But besides things
that, complex behaviors
like social behaviors as I said,
we really don't know very
much about anything else
with these animals.
We see some patterns in
their migratory behavior,
some seem to follow certain
little highways in the ocean,
but others are very random.
It's not really understood and
we've never seen them mate,
we don't know where great
whites are having their pups,
there their nursery grounds are.
Again there's some theories.
There's one off in New
York that was described
this year but a lot more
has to be done on that.
And as I mentioned earlier too,
we don't even know how many
there are in the world.
We can't decide if
they're endangered or not.
Most scientists would
think that they are
but there are those who think
the population's increasing
while others think
they're declining.
Until recently, it was
believed that great whites
only live to
about 35 years old
but a new paper
came out last year
that said that they live
well into their seventies.
So imagine this predator that's
wandering thousands of miles
in the course of a year and
living well into its seventies.
You know what kind of wisdom
might an animal
like that possess.
I don't know that we'll
ever tap into that but,
it's certainly fun
to think about.
For me, photographically,
Australia was a place
where I could get close and
make pictures of these animals
and try to show that
grace and power.
It's nothing like a great
white, it just exudes confidence
and to the degree that I could
show it through photography
their personality.
I think all animals
have personalities
and sharks certainly do.
Tigers have a different
personality than great whites,
but even within a single
species, you know,
some sharks are a
little more bold,
others are shy, this was
an animal that had a broken
dorsal fin and her
personality was pretty mean.
She was not very happy,
I think she didn't like
having that broken dorsal there.
But it was also, South
Australia was the only place
in the world that I knew of
where I could make
bottom pictures.
Most of the white shark
photos we see are up
in the water column
in the blue water.
But this was a place
where the operator
I was working with
had a bottom cage
and we could send it
down 60 to 80 feet or so
and have a chance of
seeing sharks over
the benthic region.
Now it was a tricky thing to do
because the cage
was always moving.
As the boat moved, the cage
was bouncing along the bottom
so, and there was also this
big wall of silver jacks,
these fish that would just,
like a curtain of mirrors
all around.
So in order to make this photo,
which I hadn't really
seen anything like this before,
I had to open the
door of the cage
and sort of lean out and
punch through that wall
of fish, scatter the fish,
and then for a few seconds
I saw this white shark
swimming through this forest,
coming towards this ray.
They do predate on rays,
this one didn't get eaten,
but they're also
there to eat seals,
but a different view that
might engage the reader
of the magazine
to wanna know more
about these amazing creatures.
I also worked in surface
cages out there as well.
I didn't ever get
out of the cage
because there's always
a lot of sharks.
There was usually at least
three or four of em around
and they were checking you out.
I mean they would come right in.
This was one on sort
of a rainy rough day
at the surface.
And the operator
I was working with
had a single person cage
that he didn't usually use
but he let me use it,
the reason he doesn't
let most people use it
is because it has these
big openings in it
and sometimes the white sharks
can get a little curious
and they'll start
poking their nose in.
Now usually when
they get curious,
you just poke em with
your camera housing
and they get deterred
and they swim away
but, I had one day when
about a 14 foot male
was a little over anxious
and sort of just started
coming in and he ended
up getting caught
between my strobe
cord and my strobe arm
and he ended up
ripping the strobe cord
off the camera housing,
I almost lost the entire rig,
it's about a 30, 25
thousand dollar rig.
I ended up just loosing a
three thousand dollar strobe
but, Trevor Frost, who's
in the audience tonight
was assisting me there and
he had a GoPro in the water.
So I'm gonna show a little clip
that shows me try to
wrestle this shark
to get my camera back.
At the end I didn't have fins on
so I walking up the
side of the cage.
Can't see it that great but,
anyway we'll have a look.
(soft music)
- Oh well, I'm
pretty sure I got it.
- Yeah.
So I lost the strobe
but I kept the camera
so that was the good news.
Well the other location
for this story,
the last location
for the evening here
is Cape Cod Massachusetts
my home waters
where I live and
where I started out.
What's happening in Cape Cod
is actually unique I think
in the animal kingdom.
What we have is a
newly emerging hub
for White shark activity.
There's about five known
hubs of white shark activity
in the world.
But Cape Cod is the newest one.
And it's only started
happening since about 2009,
when the white sharks
have re-emerged here.
And this would be analogous
to a new pride of lions
emerging in the Serengeti.
And I'm not aware of any
other new group of predators
just sort of taking
up residency somewhere
but that's what's
happening in Cape Cod.
It seems as though there's
some anthropological evidence
that seems to indicate
that there was a robust
seal population in Massachusetts
back in the 1600s around
the time that the pilgrims
came there but they were
wiped out by sealers.
So they were gone
for hundreds of years
but in 1972, with the marine
mammal protection act,
they were protected and these
seals have slowly come back
and overtime the sharks
have come back as well.
Chatham is sort of the
epicenter of all this activity
in the middle of Cape Cod
and they have sort of
embraced their sharkiness.
All kinds of little nick knacks
and sharky stuff for sale
in many of the gift shops,
at least until
something happens.
But yeah so this
is where I worked.
I spent two seasons out there
trying to tell this
emerging story.
Very difficult place to work.
But this is why the
sharks are there
as I mentioned the growing
number of grey seals.
This is what's for
dinner, at least if you're
a great white shark, they
seem to be singularly
focused on seals.
They're not feeding on
fish or anything else,
they just come here
to feed on the seals.
And this is an
aerial photo I made
of one of these great whites.
You can see in the
lower right of the frame
and all those seals,
they're hunting
in very very shallow water.
Most of the
literature that exist,
all of the literature
that exist says that
for a great white shark to
hunt a pinniped, a seal,
it needs about 80 feet
of water to ambush them.
But we've been
documenting predation
in as shallow as five
or 10 feet of water.
So this is a unique strategy,
unique in the world.
Not all of their
attacks are successful.
This was a grey seal
that was attacked
and got away,
but it did actually
die later so,
they're not always, I don't
know what their success rate is,
it hasn't been measured, but
that's what's going on there.
In the years since 2009,
the state biologist
with Mass State Fishery
he's a friend of mine Greg
Schumble, has been conducting
a population study.
What he does is he
goes out on a boat
with a big pulpit like this,
we use spotter planes
to help find the sharks
and then we get our
boat in position,
or he gets his boat in position
and he'll put a
little GoPro camera
on the end of a long pole
and try to get some video of it.
And each shark has
unique markings,
they might have scars or
different counter shading
patterns on them so he's
been able to identify
in just the last few years
over 200 individuals.
So you know Jaws
was about one shark,
we've got over 200 at least
and no doubt there's
gonna be a lot more.
But you can also see in
this picture I made of Greg
doing that study, how close
they come to the beach.
This is Nauset Beach in Orleans,
which is right near Chatham,
most popular beach on Cape Cod.
And I was out there
for two seasons
and everyday I'd see surfers
and boogie borders and people.
One day these guys saw
me out there in the boat
and they scratched in the words
shark with a question
mark on the beach there.
So I climbed up on
top of the pilot house
and I yelled, yes.
There is one right here.
So far we've been
able to co-exist
and the sharks seem
very discriminating
about what they're hunting
but who knows.
But photographically, this
was one of the most difficult
things I've ever done.
These are completely
wild sharks,
they can't be chummed in.
They have no interest as a rule
in coming close to the boat.
The researchers up there
have used all kinds
of attractance
and things and nothing works
to get em close to the boat.
So my first season up there,
the best I could do
was a pole cam picture.
This is a picture I made
while our boat was underway
of one of these giant
great white sharks
in that very murky water.
There's lots of currents, you
couldn't use a cage there,
you wouldn't see anything
and the currents
would blow it over.
Pretty impressive tail
though, right, shark tail.
But I eventually figured
that what I needed to do
was build a seal decoy.
So I went back to my
friends at Woods Hole
and we built this
big great seal.
We tried to make it as
authentic as possible,
like an adult grey seal.
I had the head sculpted
by a model maker
and we put cameras inside
with fiber optic cables
and I could watch in
real time and live view
back on the boat.
We had a little wet suit
carved like a seal body here
and we would deploy it day
and night, day and night,
day and night, and nothing.
Sharks had absolutely
no interest.
They were laughing as
they gave me the fingers,
they just went by.
And that was about it.
So over the winter
I went home dejected
and wasn't sure I
was gonna have story.
I didn't know if I'd
get any pictures.
But over the winter I
talked to a friend of mine
who's a veterinarian on Cape Cod
and also a shark researcher
and he had also been
working on his own
seal decoy design.
And he had perfected it.
He got it to a point where
it was a much simpler design.
A much smaller seal design,
only about three or
four feet in length.
And he said he was having a
little bit of success with this.
So I took his design and I
adapted my cameras to it.
What I needed to do
was put a wireless
underwater camera in
there that I could trigger
from hundreds of yards away,
I didn't want any
cables in the water.
And I also had to have real
time video in there as well
that I could see on the boat.
So I deployed these last summer
and the sharks were interested.
Now the trick was you wanted one
that would come up
and check it out,
but you didn't want
one that would eat it,
because that would be very bad.
And that happened, that happened
on a number of occasions
where the great white
would come up and destroy
the seal decoy.
We had ones that didn't
have cameras in em
but em, so this is
maybe 30 or 40 yards
off Monomoy beach in Chatham.
Well this picture was
published in the July issue.
The Cape Cod chamber of
commerce was especially pleased.
They sent me thank you notes.
But it's an
interesting behavior.
What's happening here
it's not like South Africa
where these animals are
breaching out of the water
and so forth,
but it is unique in the world
and there's a lot more
that needs to be studied.
I have a little video that
shows some of that decoy work.
(slow music)
so using that system
I was able to produce
the very first
under water pictures
of a great white shark
in Cape Cod waters.
One of these days where the
shark just sort of was curious,
came up to the seal and
using that rig on the boat
where I had the video I could
remotely fire the camera,
wirelessly fire it and
make these portraits.
You can see very shallow waters,
a shadow on the bottom,
maybe five feet
depth here of water.
And very murky, this one
had pilot fish with it
and this one I named Mike Tyson
because he had a little
tattoo on his face there.
I think those are scratches
from the seal but,
I think we certainly have
a very long way to go
in truly understanding
these sharks.
We may never understand
em, but each year
I think we're
peeling back layers
and learning a little bit more.
And I have to say that despite
the devastating decline
of sharks, all species of
sharks around the planet,
I think we're maybe
at a point now where
we're turning the corner,
where we're beginning to
appreciate these animals,
through photography and film
we're creating a new ethic
and maybe we're coming
to the understanding
that the world is
indeed a better place
with sharks in it.
So in closing I think
back to when I began
looking like Liberace here.
Many decades ago when
I was spending time
on stinky fishing boats,
ladeling churm into the sea
in hopes of just seeing a
shark and I didn't know then,
those decades ago that
in the years ahead,
I would actually find
myself in the company
of many many sharks and I
couldn't have known then
that I would come
to see these animals
as a species in peril.
That for all their strength,
they remain fragile and
completely powerless
against the overfishing
that's eradicating them
from our oceans.
So all these years
later I find myself
still on boats in less than
comfortable conditions,
decades spent at sea,
which is the price I pay for
just a few precious moments
underwater in the company of
these magnificent animals,
where I try to shine
a light on them
and help to tell their story.
So to end I started with
my blue shark story,
my very first and i wanted
to end with a little video
that was done while I
was on Rhode Island.
It was a one hour documentary
in the National
Geographic Channel
about my shark work and
this was in Rhode Island
when I was looking for Makos
but I found my old
friends the blue sharks.
So that'll be the wrap up.
(soft music)
My Mako story continues,
this is the third
location in which I've worked.
I started in San
Diego California.
Then earlier this year
I was in New Zealand.
But these are my home waters.
New England is where I
first started diving.
So over the last several
days we've seen some Makos,
but they've been
a little bit shy,
they haven't really come
in close to the camera
but today was a spectacular
day with blue sharks.
Blue sharks were the very
first species of shark
that I ever photographed,
I think it was 1982
when I was out in
these same waters
and spent an afternoon
swimming with a blue shark.
So I have a real fun
place in my heart
for these animals.
They're also
stunningly beautiful.
They're shaped like an aircraft
with these big pectoral fins
that are like the
wings of a glider
in this long slender
fusologe like body
and their Indigo backs,
and their discolorations
is really quit exquisite.
To see one or two
on recent trips,
was sort of the
average but today,
we really hit the jackpot.
We had over a dozen, I'd
say maybe 15 or more.
And it's a nice opportunity
when the sun begins to go down
to start making some
dramatic pictures.
So I love to work in low light
where I have some
control over the colors
and the movement of the animals,
a great opportunity
for photography
even though it wasn't
the prime target.
And what I'm trying
to do with this
is bring readers into
the world of the shark.
When you see one, when
you actually see an animal
like a Mako shark underwater,
you just can't
believe that nature
has sculpted
something so perfect.
Seeing a dozen or more
blue sharks here today
was a hopeful thing for me.
I know that their numbers
have been dessimated
throughout the Atlantic
Ocean and this is somewhat
of an anomaly.
But it does give me hope.
I believe we're at a moment
where the traction is occurring,
we're making some momentum,
and if this continues, if we
all keep beating that drum,
I think the future
could be bright.
Thank you very much.
(audience applause)